okay very very big news for the David
Pakman show
starting this week we are going to be
launching the David Pakman show on WC PT
in Chicago Illinois one of the biggest
and only remaining true independent
progressive talk radio stations in the
United States we're already on AM 950 in
Minneapolis WC PT they carry Thom
Hartmann etc etc unfortunately Norman
gold man has has ended his program and I
don't know the exact circumstances but I
think that part of it was related to
lack of financial viability which is
extraordinarily sad and fortunately the
David Pakman show
thanks to the support of members is in a
position to distribute our radio show at
no cost to radio stations to 200
stations every single day WC PT came to
us and said David were interested in
running your show and I was in a
position it's so amazing because three
years ago four years ago the idea of
getting on WC PT was mind-blowing the
idea that we could get the show on one
of the major progressive radio stations
in the United States in a market like
Chicago now it's exciting but we are in
a position where it's a great thing to
have but we have a great base of support
from the audience because of the
membership program because of all of the
other things that we're doing and so we
are not in a position where they can
influence how the show goes and this is
I don't want to name names here um but a
couple years ago I was speaking to a
notable progressive broadcaster and they
told me you know we were on a particular
station for a while and they came to us
and they said you know listen we love
the show we're a progressive station but
we're in a more moderate religious area
could you avoid the pro-choice stuff on
the show because whenever you do
pro-choice stuff we get complaints and
we want to keep you on but we really
can't have you doing the pro-choice
stuff and they this broadcaster Rafi
used to acquiesce and ultimately they
were kicked off with a radio station if
any one of these stations and we love
being on with them if any of them came
to me and said David we're gonna have to
get rid of the show unless you change
your view on this or that I would say
bye and that's it
because we don't depend on them for
financial support because we have
support from you so when when I talk
about the membership program makes
everything possible it's not this vague
amorphous thing it literally makes it so
that our show can exist regardless of
what any program director says needs to
happen regardless of what people calling
in to a radio station want to hear on
their airwaves so massive news WC PT in
Chicago were thrilled to be on but we no
longer need to be on in order for this
program to be viable thanks to everybody
who has signed up for membership now
it's not just Chicago that I want to
mention we are also making a big
entrance this week into Washington DC DC
TV a very large a community channel in
Washington DC is going to be picking up
the television version of the David
Pakman show and this is also just a
fantastic bonus again we don't need to
be on these stations we want to be on
these stations as a public service and
just so exciting Pat I mean two major
major markets for us that we've been
trying to crack for a while now yeah
this is awesome great to know that we're
gonna be heard in Chicago and Washington
DC even better for me to know that I
don't I don't have to start
self-censoring I don't have to switch up
Mike on commentary it's make it less
controversial we can keep things here on
the show exactly as they are yes we can
and we will and this is a program that
we are giving to them for free we're not
beholden to them we're beholden to the
audience not to individual stations or
anybody else fortunate because shows
have ended over lack of audience support
so thanks to everybody we're off to an
amazing start in 2019 more than 500 new
members so far in this early part of the
year less than two months in
two major new markets for us Chicago and
Washington DC and a bunch of other
exciting things in the works including
possibly a live taping of the show here
in Boston which hopefully the reaction
from the audience was very positive when
I floated that idea last week hopefully
I'll have more information about that
for you probably in a couple of weeks
we're sort of thinking about the
different logistics